[Music]
we're back
yes we are dumb now you aren't here
you're not here where you normally are
you're there it looks like are you in
the shower is that right is that a
shower joint but it looks like i i put
the curtain like halfway in my screen do
you think that was wise well it just it
looks like half disco curtain half
shower curtain but you look good if i do
it anymore that way you'll see my bed
and i didn't want you to see my bed
that way then it's like quite dylan
you've smashed it you're filming are you
having a nice time an actor's life for
you etc lovely stuff done but obviously
i miss being in the studio and being
with you and having a nice time on two
lovely chairs well we have a fantastic
guest today who we're going to bring on
but billy
uh yeah i think it's always nice to
start with a riddle don't you because we
like a riddle you and i and we've been
quite we've been quite successful with
riddles at conventions recently and
riddles on the show so you're ready for
a riddle i could go a riddle actually
done because i've been learning lines
and i feel like my mind needs to go
somewhere else so give me give me a nice
riddle come on dog okay darling now
here's a riddle from zach from
florida
new york
california okay i'm go just for the heck
of it i'm gonna say
the squidgy part on the bottom of your
index no just above great goal up up up
oh no wait go along go along go along no
the other way the other way the other
way the other way either no the other
way the other way yeah that's it
keep going that way towards your thumb
no no towards your thumb
towards your thumb
towards your thumb
keep going towards your thumb towards
your thumb towards your thumb towards
you stop now go up
stop now go you're right
stop let's say there iowa pretty good
john i'm getting a nod from john
yeah i'm getting a nod from john that
was like this
which is pretty good
well done
you took a long way around i see
what you did there i think we should do
that road trip
for our two year anniversary we'll do
that road trip from here
along up and there and we'll stop in
iowa and we'll go and see our friend the
riddle yes lovely is that and we can do
riddles and tongue twisters along the
way but here's a riddle from zach in
iowa that says this here we go
i am a vessel
without hinges
lock
or lid
yet within my walls the golden treasure
is hid
a vessel dom
that using the word vessel makes you
think that's important doesn't it yes
now to to define the word vessel it's
usually something that holds something
right it's a vessel is that
kind of a good dictionary
things or or
also it makes me think of a boat
it's a boat called
two but i mean boats have hinges and
locks and lids don't they yeah
but what what was the thing what is the
gut what is it it holds a golden what
the final uh line here says yeah within
my walls a golden treasure is his is the
word golden like is that a metaphor of
something kind of expensive and and you
know kind of shiny or is it actually
something gold in terms of color
somewhat somewhat it is it's gold
it's gold billy it this thing is
actually gold and it's within the walls
and it's a vessel like if i were to say
oh my god the sunset god it's beautiful
this the golden rays are falling upon me
here we go give it you one more time
bills
i am a vessel without hinges lock or
get within my walls
golden treasure is head
so what's kind of yellowy goldy
no clothes
no
well i thought honey is it the pyramids
not the pyramids i thought beehive
because honey can kind of be gold i
thought it was on there it
yeah i thought that was quite good
actually i'd say golden honey is kind of
like a silver
vessel
without hinges
lead
what other thing what was it
looks like should we ask johnny for a
clue
yeah ask him if he could give us a clue
would you i'm trying trying to think of
like a good clue that's not too obvious
is it is it in the natural world is it
something that yes so it's not a
man-made thing it's something in the
natural world it's a natural world it's
a living
it's part of the living world part of
the living world maybe oh
so it must be an animal
what animal is gold think of a dinosaur
or a dinosaur you said that is that
ceranosaurus is that triceratops they're
not gold
um something very old something very old
is it my grandmother
getting warm it's a granny boy
you said mother that's in the ballpark
mother's in the ballpark
is it a womb again you're in the
ballpark you're on the field it's some
something that holds because the golden
treasure is probably a baby animal maybe
so
i said
a vessel
you're on the field you're very on the
field
an egg it's an egg i've done it
wow
it's an egg of course an egg foo
well that's very good
it's a very good one well done
hey don can i read out this by uh a
ramirez who uh watches us on youtube
and uh we actually met him
we met him at the live the very first
live taping
of the friendship onion which we enjoyed
didn't we john oh we absolutely loved it
this uh this message is uh so lovely
that i've put my glasses on to take it
seriously please
here we go listen to this from a ramirez
beautifully written he says
i am a huge fan of the friendship onion
and was surprised by the intellectual
curiosity kindness and light-hearted
attitude you express on the show along
with the manner in which you do not
necessarily fixate on giving an answer
or viewpoint that is anything but honest
and sincere regardless of the
vulnerability shared a contrary
impression given by other hollywood
celebrities do you have any
recommendations for philosophy or other
literature that help shape your
positivity and jolly disposition that
you exude because often with great
wisdom can come great sorrow but you
seem to have found the balance of
silence sorrow in the face of such
wisdom and intellectual curiosity listen
to that job oh my goodness
wow there's a lot of big words there do
you have any books or anything you've
read or listened to in philosophy that
you would like to share with the people
of the fellowship onion fellowship
friendship i'll actually say telling
this to my trainer today
uh a very often
i mean i listen to alan watts quite a
lot he's an interesting chap if you guys
are interested in in philosophy and and
someone who
uh spent a lot of his life exploring zen
buddhism um but there is a relatively
old now pbs documentary narrated by
richard gere about the life of buddha
that includes some wonderful
allegories and stories and legends and
tales beautiful music you know indian
based music and very often if i am maybe
cooking in my house and i just want
something under the background or if i'm
meditating or i go to sleep at night
i'll either have a little alan watts or
a little documentary about buddha and
you can find both of those things on
youtube thank you lovely stuff well done
dom no
do you think it's time now to uh bring
on our wonderful guest for this week
well yes but do you not have any wisdom
of your own to share for goodness sake
oh i'm sorry tom i thought i thought you
were you hit the nail on the head
um off the top of my head why don't we
say
um some lovely lovely
quick little thoughts from um and i
don't know if i've ever pronounced this
name right t-shnat hang mm-hmm
who's uh has has a lovely positive
outlook on life that i think is well
worth looking at and if you fancy trying
meditation um i would have a look at um
paramahansa yogananda i agree that's one
of the most uh
incredibly influential books of my
entire life the autobiography of a yogi
which you bought for me many moons ago
my friend and i've never bought your
book since i thought that was enough
that's
that's absolutely true well
with that in mind why don't we bring on
our illustrious guest uh this week mr
chris
mancini
now i'm i'm not in the studio um as
we've already mentioned and we know but
yes i wish i was because i've got a
lovely guest lovely guest this week um
and you're sitting with them so you know
and you can smell them whereas i can yes
but everything else i can see them and
hear them chris smells of elderberry jam
yes
that would have been my guess do you
want me to give you some background on
chris mancini dom yeah go on while i'm
sat here reading the blurb as well cool
all right here we go chris this is all
about you
chris mancini is a writer
comedian
filmmaker podcaster and also parent he
has written on everything from soap
operas to parenting books to comics to
horror films which are all closely
related much more than you would think
he has screened and spoken at various
prestigious festivals and conventions
including slam dance and comic-con in
san diego he made his first stop-motion
film at age 12 and he's been trying to
get someone to greenlight a sequel ever
since he has written and directed
award-winning short films horror comedy
feature film asylum for
gate and was a writer and producer on
earbuds the podcasting documentary for
comedy dynamics his published works
include pacify me a handbook for the
freaked out new dad from simon and
schuster
the comedy film nerds guide to movies
from morgan james and long ago and far
away from white cat entertainment with
rise of the kung fu dragon master
releasing in the fall of this year so
he's doing it what tom he's up to a lot
i have it right here
chris chris gifted us both a copy of
rise of the kung fu dragon master right
here so i'll save one for you
that's not even out yet oh it's hot it's
steaming hot off the press with him
steaming
what about the also what yes yes darling
sorry tom i was going to ask about long
ago and far away it didn't it didn't
happen if you bring one of them in for
us did he well i think long ago and far
away is right here oh brilliant because
that does look very good and if you
don't mind we could start talking about
that dom because i know you like a
graphic novel as much as the next man
and then that one looks like a brilliant
one so chris first of all welcome to the
friendship onion thanks guys i am um
tickled pink to be here this is awesome
i um was uh really excited been a big
fan so it's really cool uh welcome to
podcasting gentlemen um yeah we feel
welcome it's been i think we've just
moved past a calendar year with the
podcasting and we we're still also um
learning as much as we can you had a
podcast for you were telling me before
we started working how long a decade
yeah how many filmmakers we did a uh we
did and we did a feature film for
earbuds the podcasting documentary a
book and we i was also one of the
founders of the la podcast festival nice
so i really doubled down on podcasting
now i'm here to tell you about public
goods now this is a fantastic company
public goods is the one stop shop for
sustainable high quality everyday
essentials made from clean ingredients
at an affordable price everything from
personal care household products to
coffee
toilet paper shampoo even dog food and a
public goods is your new everything
store thoughtfully designed for the
conscious consumer i love it this soap
yes
the bar soap shampoo yes
and knowing what's in your products and
where they come from is very important
they use a membership model to keep
costs low and they pass on even more
savings to the customers and best of all
you can make your first purchase with no
obligation join hundreds of thousands of
others who have switched to the new
everything store and we've worked out an
awesome deal receive 15 off your first
public goods order with no minimum
purchase that's right they are so
confident that you will absolutely love
their products and come back again and
again that they are giving you fifteen
dollars to spend on your first purchase
you have nothing to lose just go to
publicgoods.com or use the code onion at
checkout that's p-u-b-l-i-c-g-o-o-d-s
forward slash onion to receive your
fifteen dollars off your first purchase
since starting to incorporate magic
spoon into my daily morning routine i
have noticed fewer cravings throughout
the day
sometimes i can even skip second
breakfast
also i've started going back to the gym
and uh sometimes you don't want to have
those protein shakes or anything like
that
magic spoon is full of protein it's a
guilt-free snack it's fantastic here's
some facts
zero grams of sugar
13 to 14 grams of protein and only four
net grams of carbs in each serving the
honey nut flavor has one gram of sugar
only 140 calories a serving is keto
friendly gluten free grain free soy free
and low carb
you can build your own box the nine
available flavors to build your very own
custom bundle are
cocoa fruity frosted peanut butter
cookies and cream maple waffle blueberry
muffins cinnamon roll and my favorite
honey nut
even more exciting
magic spoon has brought back their
cereal bars they were so popular they
brought them back forever as far as they
are concerned very convenient on the go
and uh
a good companion for your cereal
grab a custom bundle of cereal and be
sure to use our promo code at checkout
and you'll save five dollars off your
order and magic spoon is so confident in
their product it's backed with a hundred
percent happiness guarantee if so if you
don't like it for any reason they'll
refund your money no questions asked
remember get your next delicious bowl of
guilt-free cereal at
magicspoon.com slash onion and use the
code onion to save five dollars off
thank you magic spoon for sponsoring
this episode
billy you want to talk about graphic
novels first and i think why not why not
yeah if you don't mind because i was
just
looking at the the last one you did um
uh long ago and far away
that was the one before the
the one that you're about to promote
right
yes and uh that one was like kind of
like my love letter to fantasy even with
uh just i grew up reading these books
like of course of tolkien and uh narnia
and i always thought well these kids
always go to this fantasy world they
save the world from the evil witch but
then when they come back what happens to
them what happens if a kid then becomes
30 he's in haters runs a comic book
store and he has to go back into that
world again as an adult and just makes
things worse so that was the premise of
long gone far away so it's a comedy and
a fantasy kind of combined it's like
kind of my love of fantasy with also my
love of comedy and kind of putting it
all together and how um somebody deals
with that lost lustre of life that they
had when they were 13 but now they're an
adult and they how do they get that back
that
kind of childhood wonder to actually
become the hero they once were at 13.
did you did you know relatively right
from the start that this was actually
going to be a graphic novel as opposed
to a movie script or a tv show or
something
no i just kind of had the story and it
went through a couple of um development
cycles it was like you know a tv show
then maybe a movie and then it really
started like then it kind of like um
settled on my hard drive for uh for a
little while and i was like you know
what this is a graphic novel it really
is and uh so i kind of retooled it put
it together and then um put it together
with um a mark wade he has a a company
thrillbent that was online and then the
funding fell through so he helped me
kind of get it started on kickstarter
then it got picked up after that so it
was it's a long process to get this uh
story made but it was one of those
stories as you guys know
that some stories just want to be told
no matter how hard it is or how long
that the time passes it's like that one
out of like the hundred stories that i
had on the hard drive that one's like no
i'm coming out that's the one that's uh
that's going to get made as the story as
you told it there and what i read
earlier just sounds fantastic because
that sort of
you know
in the real world when you're having an
adventure when you're 13 or 14 years old
and how how
kind of what a massive part of your life
that can be
and then
extend that and make it about an actual
fantasy character who goes to another
world and then and then they're back in
the normal world living with their mom
and i i just thought it was a it was a
brilliant premise and uh
i think it's actually crying out to be a
film or a tv show and might i suggest my
friend dominic monahan to play the lead
who i think would be yeah i think i
would be fantastic at the lead and i'm
looking at the cover i don't think it's
a bad idea guys i'm looking at the cover
of the graphic novel here billy there's
a there's a guy
there's a guy just to the lead's right
who looks kind of
happy and maybe his friend more than
anything else yeah really
is this guy
that guy to the right will call him that
guy is very small
what's his name
chris
yeah what is it his name is phil he's
the uh kind of the sidekick that goes
along for the ride that gets through the
um gets through the portal as well
really yep i'll do that thank you very
much chris what about your journey bills
with uh
graphic novels over the years because we
have spent enough time with each other
and with other people who are into
graphic novels where things have been
kind of
swapped around and stuff and obviously
you have a 16 year old son has he ever
got into graphic novels no not really
and even with us going to um
conventions like yourself chris you know
and
you know what it's like there's great
artists there and
you know and and wonderful stories that
are being told but he's it's never been
a
something he's got really into um well
maybe he doesn't like crowds so that's
yeah maybe but even even when i bring
him back uh um
a graphic novel it's never been
something he really
other than and that's more a comic book
he he got into the flash for a while so
he was reading some graphic novels of uh
the flash stories
but uh
no not really but i've always enjoyed
occasionally i forget about graphic
novels a lot of the time you know you
you pick up novels and and i forget and
i was at a
um a store there the other day at
bookstore and they had a good graphic
novel section i thought god i must try
and figure out you know which one should
have been read in the last few years and
get back on that you know
what ones would you suggest chris
there's a ton of really good stuff um
there's a lot of things like uh like the
superhero ones obviously but then if
you're into heart the hellboy ones are
really good and then there's a couple
really good sci-fi ones like ascender
and descender are really good um the me
you love in the dark is kind of a creepy
short horror story and then
uh sandman's always classic they've
revisited that i don't i now i could go
on and on and on for graphic novels but
uh what um what genre do you like the
most for me uh probably sci-fi sci-fi
then i would recommend
um there's a really good i think it was
it was a jeff lemire i can't remember
the
writer's name um ascender is really good
i think you would like that and then
there's actually a sequel descender that
takes everything in the sci-fi version
of the story
and then puts it in almost like a
fantasy setting with robots so it's it's
really an interesting story yeah it's
one of my favorite things i was saying
one of my favorite things to bring on a
plane because
there's there's a kind of there's an
ease to kind of drop in in and out of a
graphic novel much more than maybe a
novel that that uh is just written
because
i don't know maybe maybe the pictures
kind of allow you to know where you are
a little easier or remind you where you
have once been and on a on a long-haul
flight
uh usually i'm kind of jumping in out
stuff i watch a film yeah eat some food
maybe listen to some music read
something and reading a graphic novel on
a plane has always been like for me the
perfect time
uh and that's the reason too like you
said you could jump in and out of it and
uh you know in case
if you want to take a nap or whatever
right it's it's yeah it's a great thing
to read and then i've always found two
now
that i have so many graphic novels i'm
running out of space so i've gotten i've
started to get a lot more on digital and
it's been a lot easier then you know you
just bring your tablet and you could
have like your library with you to read
yeah i had to throw out
or or give away i should say a whole
kind of half a bookcase of graphic
novels over the years i've been very
lucky people being like oh check this
out like you today check this out have a
read have a read yeah and you find
yourself thinking okay i'm going to try
and just keep the classics because they
do take up quite a bit of space you know
and chris chrissie's new one will be
within those uh classics now oh you can
put that in your classic section
absolutely excellent um you know
podcasting has been around for a while
now but if you've been doing it for 10
years you were certainly at a point
where it probably hadn't caught fire in
the way that it's done now no we were
kind of one of the early adopters to the
point when we created the company comedy
film nerds about with comedians
reviewing movies and we added the
podcast actually it was originally just
a website and that's when you know my
partner graham elwin who i started with
he said well we need to add a podcast
and of course everyone's question after
that was what's a podcast
and we added that and then the podcast
became far more popular than the website
so we actually kind of um put all the
resources into there and it kind of grew
from there and we
had fans all over the world in fact in
the documentary we actually go and visit
like the comedy film nerds fans into
like australia and japan and it's it was
really fun but the thing about
podcasting is you don't realize how far
your reach goes that's what's so amazing
about it you know how many people you're
talking to um
so it's there's no medium really quite
like it and and with your interest in
film you that was that was the best
subject to
pick
have you just have you just done one
podcast over the years have you done a
few absolutely that was the uh like we
just i loved film grew up you know
watching film would always go into the
blockbusters grab the vhs tapes if
anybody in the audience remembers what
those are
[Laughter]
but then um we ended in 2019 then i
started a a couple other new podcasts i
started white cat entertainment like in
about 2020 right when the pandemic was
hitting which is a great time to start a
new company and a lot of new endeavors
it's really was really helpful
so it's kind of a spiritual successor
called what are you watching and i
interview comedians and entertainment
pros and kind of find out what they're
doing and then what they're watching
because i think you could get a lot of
insight from what someone is watching if
they actually also make entertainment
too it kind of gives you another kind of
layer of why they might like a show or a
movie as much and then the other podcast
i started was because things were going
so crazy with the pandemic i wanted to
create a podcast to help people with
anxiety and uh sleeplessness and
insomnia
so i created the quiet journeys of
professor atwood about a professor that
goes to all these different journeys
with a bed of like music and sound
effects that can slowly kind of put you
off to sleep through narrative
storytelling so
that i created too
and that one's uh that one's been doing
pretty well what's that one called chris
the quiet journeys of professor atwood
so it's like a i call it a comedy
storytelling anti-anxiety science travel
um relaxation podcast it's kind of a
hybrid of all those things wow and like
you said there's been a there's been an
uptick in a lot of people trying to
manage their anxiety during bit of a
need for it yeah
yeah it's crazy yeah it is crazy well
in terms of films
since you you grew up having films be so
formative for you
what were the ones in those years in
those kind of you know 9 10 11 12 year
old years where movies become so at
least for me at least became so
important what are the standout movies
for you you know i grew up as a kid i
grew up on the live-action disney movies
it was like you know the herbie rides
again the love bug and all of those but
then you know
yeah yeah exactly all of this and uh
um but as i got older then i you know
i'm a kid i'm a child of the 80s so it
was all like the spielberg stuff and
goonies and you know indiana jones and
this of course star wars and all of that
kind of like um storytelling using
adventure and science fiction and um but
there wasn't a lot of fantasy that was
the one thing that was really missing
because the effects didn't weren't at
that level yet that you could actually
have believable fantasy you could still
do models and spaceships but for some
reason no one could figure out you know
elves and trolls so
[Laughter]
but so that was the one thing i was
always read fantasy books like why can't
i get a good fantasy you know movie and
uh until of course lord of the rings and
harry potter changed all of that you
know we we we had like the best we could
get
when i did enjoy these movies was conan
you know yeah
there was a star crystal
what's that dark crystal crystal yes
that's pretty good and then i remember
there was
a couple super bad low budget ones like
this will do a deep dive into imdb but
hawk the slayer was one that was insane
[Laughter]
but that was yeah
but that was that was kind of what i was
i grew up on it was always the sci-fi
adventure you know in the comedies and
all of all of those movies that just
kind of like oh i'm gonna be watching
films all the time forever right
i love that sound
because that is the sound of another
sale on shopify the all-in-one commerce
platform to start run
and grow your business
shopify gives entrepreneurs the
resources that was once reserved for big
businesses so the upstart startups and
established businesses alike can sell
everywhere synchronize online
and effortlessly stay informed
scaling your business is a journey of
endless possibility
reach customers online and across social
networks with an ever growing suite of
channel integrations and apps including
facebook instagram tick tock pinterest
and all the other ones
more than a store shopify grows with you
this is possibility powered by shopify
go to shopify.com
onion all lowercase for a free 14-day
trial and get full access to shopify's
entire suite of features grow your
business with shopify today go to
shopify.com onion right now shopify.com
i think i've spoken about this before
on on the podcast dom
but
like when
because i i may be slightly older than
you guys
but i was there when video just came out
and like before blockbuster and the
video stores were sometimes just the
store at the end of the street
or
little stores had just started to pop up
and there was basically the same five or
six films
in every store and i've tried to work
out i even asked mark odesky the
producer of lauda rings and other people
about why that would be
but like every video store that we went
to it was
pete jackson's bad taste
and
the wild bunch
warriors
uh
and that was that was like the big
three
and everybody watched and re-watched
those films
do you have a memory of that chris or
was that was that before your time was
it blockbuster with a a store full of
videos
that was definitely a little bit before
like my uh um my memory is more of the
blockbuster where you would go in and it
would still be four movies but there
would be a thousand copies of each one
you know
like
you know rows and rows and rows and when
a new one came out it was impossible to
get it because everyone had ordered it
i remember trying to get rambo for about
two months yeah yeah and like you
couldn't you couldn't get the ones that
you wanted because there's
and then when you went into the indies
and the the lesser known movies there
was one copy of each so if there was any
other film fan in your city they had
already gotten it yeah
right
yeah it's crazy where that's all gone i
mean obviously it was it was a little
bit of
a little kind of
piece of my week
every so often would be the
two hours or so that i would spend
browsing in a video store and then
became a you know a dvd store and that's
kind of gone now when billy and i moved
to
new zealand obviously we got to know
restaurants we got to know cafes we got
to know bars and things like that and
another thing that we got to know was
video shops you know there was a there
was a kind of
almost like a blockbuster type video
shop right in the center there where you
could get all the stuff that you would
know but there was an absolutely
fantastic video shop called arrow street
video that not only had
a few blockbusters but prided itself on
having real deep cuts in movies and they
had a great section of staff that could
recommend stuff to you so you might go
in and say you know i've been watching
three or four french films in a row and
i really like them is there anything you
recommend they'd be like yeah there's
these eight films here and you should do
this and here's an animated french film
and they were fantastic that was one of
the best video shots i've ever been into
yeah yeah and there's like a couple
movies where you know that if the owners
or the people that work there like if
they have these movies you know they're
going to have like a a crazy good
selection of like you said like deep
cuts like and actually peter jackson's
like meet the feebles is one of them
if the video store had that we're like
okay well now there's going to be a um
a plentiful bounty of riches of obscure
movies that i'm really going to enjoy i
think tarantino worked in a video shop
didn't he and i just i just think like i
mean tarantino's so animated in in life
he's so animated about movies it would
have just been a real amazing moment to
have walked into a video shop in the
early 90s or you know kind of mid-80s
type thing and have a young tarantino
come over to you and be like you gotta
watch this italian western or yeah you
know you got to watch this this french
film that no one has ever seen before
that would just be an incredible moment
and i'm sure like he was always like
someday i'm going to make these movies
like okay quentin your break's over in
10 minutes right right i'm sure you get
that a lot so that whole culture behind
the video shoppers kind of died though
is there still one remaining blockbuster
in the country or has that died too
because there was for a long time this
last great blockbuster in the united
states there was actually a documentary
about it too yeah called the last
literally the last blockbuster i don't
know if it's still open or not that's a
good question i uh the only the only i
was telling elijah this story the
weekend the only time i've ever been
arrested in my life
i was seeing a blockbuster video yeah
you didn't pay a late fee uh no it's a
little bit more than that but
i um
i've been kind of like i've been thrown
into the back of police vans at football
grounds when groups around me were
fighting and i was just like oh i'm just
in a group of
40 people it had nothing to do with it
and you kind of get you know a slap on
the wrist and taken away
this the story of shame about me being
arrested in uh just just outside
actually blockbuster video is um
it always starts when you're drunk i was
drunk and um i went to blockbuster with
my girlfriend and my best mate tom
to rent the wesley snipes classic uh
blade
which i didn't have in my house i
thought you were going to say demolition
man would go ahead demolition is also a
classic a young sandra bullock who
doesn't like that um
so i you know drunk whatever had planned
on buying blade
a couple of weeks ago in manchester and
it kind of slipped my mind but i
remember seeing it in a video shop to
buy for something like
five or six pounds
and though obviously those shops were
closed so i went into blockbuster and
they were renting it for like four
pounds and i was like oh for an extra
pound i could actually buy this and have
this forever i'm just gonna nick it
terrible i know terrible
so
um i tried to nick it you know like put
it down the back of my jeans type thing
walked out as i walked out i was grabbed
by a security guy and you know what's
really funny in all of these moments i
was talking about with billy and sean
and elijah at the weekend as well in
these moments of feeling like you're
close to death you know like a
near-death experience or
being naughty the overwhelming emotion
that i have is one of embarrassment i'm
always just embarrassed you know that oh
my god i'm going to die like this how
embarrassing oh my god i just got
arrested like this how embarrassing and
i remember he grabbed me
and i kind of went oh man i'm sorry
about that i was just messing around he
was like no no you're like you're not
leaving we're calling the police lock
the doors put me in the broom cover type
thing and i was trying to get out of it
whilst being really kind of embarrassed
going i feel so stupid like i'm sorry
can i just can i just give you a tenner
the film was you know four quid or
whatever to rent he's like no we're
calling the police police showed up
they asked me what had gone on
and i was like well i don't know i just
tried to nick here you know blah blah
blah and they're like right get in the
car so i got in the car
my girlfriend and tom are outside and
they're like what's going on and i
couldn't i wasn't really allowed to
speak i thought i'll talk to you later i
talked to you later this is like pre
mobile phones pre-cell phones
oh god once they went to the police
station in long sight they put me in a
holding cell forever because that's what
they do when they arrest you they're
going to make it as hard for you as
possible so that you don't do it again
so i was in a holding cell until like
six in the morning
yeah and they probably arrested me at
like
i don't know midnight something like
that so
and then pull me out
take a statement
caution me all this kind of stuff and at
this point i'm sober i've got a hangover
you know i'm feeling terrible and uh
and that was it and i left but it's the
only time that i've been arrested and it
was uh it was all based around
blockbuster video so
there you go you know um good times in
blockbuster video you ever been arrested
in blockbuster video chris uh you know
what i haven't but um if i did it would
probably be for yelling at one of the
clerks for like you know making fun of a
movie or something yeah yeah it would be
something like even more ridiculous than
trying to steal something yeah yeah i'll
remember
i did really love that first blade from
i know you know wesley snipes had a bad
rap over the years for you know known
for you know not being the easiest guy
to work with i thought it was great as
blade that opening sequence where tracy
lords picks up the guy and takes him to
the abattoir and they're all dancing and
the blood comes right through the
ceiling that's really fun i remember
saying to my friends when the matrix
came out and they'd introduced like
strict bullet time into the matrix i was
like yeah what they did in the matrix is
extraordinary and incredible and changed
movies they're kind of hinting at it in
blade a couple of times there's like
almost like
half bullet time you see a little
clearly they've they've been testing out
the way that it works and you see a
little moment where something happens
and the camera kind of
like swoops around you know oh yeah that
was when blade came out that was like
cutting edge special effects when that
when that trailer came out we're like oh
my god yeah this is this is really cool
yeah and
uh you know they they're rebooting blade
because i know um marvel got the rights
back yeah is it mahershala ali yep he's
going to be such a fantastic actor so
definitely looking uh looking forward to
that but yeah there was
i think there were three played movies
yeah ryan reynolds was in one right yes
there's an absolute weapon in one of
them and there was there was a tv a very
short-lived tv series
uh for blade i think it was one i don't
remember what it was on but yeah that
didn't last long so blade's ready for a
reboot blade is definitely ready for
reboot there's supposed to be a moment
in blade three i think
because i know the guy who wrote it and
produced it where
i don't know what's going on here but
wesley blade wesley snipes is lying like
on a slab
and he's supposed to
have his eyes open and wesley snipes
refused to open his eyes so the feeling
that so they digitally added on his eyes
after in post-production that that's
what he was like nah i'm good
isn't that crazy no i don't want to
don't want to but you're supposed to be
awake wesley but i don't want to yeah
all right we'll do it later that that's
a really weird thing to like um that's a
weird hill to die on as an actor like
well can you just open your eyes nope
not gonna do it not gonna do it um
well let's go back a little bit because
we're because we're doing graphic we're
doing graphic i've got a hair on my
manchester united cat which is driving
me crazy we're doing graphic novels and
podcasting i want to jump around a
little bit i wanted to ask you about if
there's someone out there
who's
listening to podcasts enjoying podcasts
is
is keen on potentially starting up a
podcast in their own house which i know
a lot of people are doing and the
markets being flooded and all that kind
of stuff but
what advice would you give to someone
who is thinking of doing something kind
of you know from their bedroom
in terms of a startup podcast thing well
the good news is it's like you need very
little equipment now so you could
literally get started for probably under
100 if you wanted to but i think the
main thing is the you know you hear it
all the time is content like if you're
going to start a podcast what are you
passionate about and what can you
bring to the table that someone else
isn't already doing so i think if you
combine those two things like something
you're really passionate about and
something that you're doing a little
differently that's a good starting place
because the thing about podcasts is i'm
sure you guys have discovered over the
last year and a half is that um when you
have a format you don't have to stick to
it you could add segments you could
subtract segments you could change the
flow of the show you could do whatever
you want it's a podcast so
that's the other advice i would give is
don't be married to like a format that
you start in because if something is
working better or you enjoy something
else better change it up there's no
rules brilliant billy you could do a
podcast about the borg because you're
fascinated
totally about the borg i think one day
we will actually meet the borg but dom
it's not a day that we should look
forward to but anyway are they a
nefarious group of people yeah they're
not easy resistance is futile i know i
hear you but are the only people that
are quote unquote friends with the borg
of the borg or do they have the
occasional human that they're pally with
no no one no the the borg only want to
make more borg
if they like you you get assimilated oh
great i'd love to be assimilated sounds
fantastic and if they don't like you you
get a simulated so i mean as i've said
dom it's slower
do you like star trek
big fan of star trek i was going to say
too if you've seen the new series uh
picard the um
the last couple episodes the uh borg got
uh
time travel
there was a time travel adventure with
picard and now the borg are suddenly
helpful to the federation so things have
changed a little bit with the borg
i've got a problem with that chris so do
i actually as a as a star trek fan and a
next generation fan i was like the borg
was always the big bad that star trek
could never the enterprise could never
negotiate with starfleet could never
negotiate with don't undercut that leave
that as the worst possible bad guy i
completely there you go
i
and and i feel that
about all movies and tvs i i don't like
it when they say they set a parameter
and then they just change it you know
that kind of annoys me and and all kind
of tv and film i'm like no i like that
leave me with that memory you know
and don't start messing around with that
but what was i going to say there oh
yeah so this podcast that you're doing
i'm sorry for your last billy
then you won the other and i would never
know i would never say anything against
picard he's my favorite captain
but anyway
until i get the chance to play the
captain
and uh
you would be
marvelous can i just say that i'm just
putting that out into the ether
well a couple of weeks ago we had a
little sequence where
he was a skirmish off the starboard
bound and billy was a captain and he was
incredible really you'd be brilliant and
you might be wondering chris what would
dom be
you know first mate
would they be down in the engine room
would they be in charge of you know
whatever
i'll tell you it'd be chris it'd be the
cleaner yeah
and all right
just just the toilets so the only time
you meet his character is when when
someone's had a good poo
and somebody's got to get in there and
clean that bowl that's when you would
see john
yeah
anyway happy to do so as well also on on
the ships on the star trek ships as you
know you know the doors kind of go shh
but in the toilet
i have added a lock so that if you are
taking a [ __ ] you can actually lock it
because obviously any motion
opens it and if you're in the middle of
kicking your legs back if it's a big one
you might open it so i fashion locks in
the star trek toilets and i give out
tiny little uh peppermints
it sounds like chief engineer would be
pop i would like to be promoting
actually have a think about it captain
that would be the second season though
but um
well we're going to talk about but
before we go on to your podcast that
just
reminded me of something dom with this
and the door that opens i i don't know
if you'll remember but
um or chris if you've spent any time in
the uk
but um british real
changed their the toilets where it
wasn't just a manual lock
it it was a it was like it was like a
star trek door it went shh and when it
closed you press the close button
but you also had to press a lock
and no one ever remember because it
seems weird to press close and lock
in a sort of you know
and one time
i i did press the open thinking nobody
was going to be in it
and there was a there was an elderly
lady sitting on the throne there
she wasn't pleased i wasn't pleased
i wrote a long letter to british real
anyway as i was about to say i like the
idea of your i like the idea of your
your new podcast chris and then because
it sounds like it takes your love of
movies and
uh tv but then as you say you're now
tying it into
so i suppose um i just started uh
listening to one there i think or it
might have been your old one but
you're then talking about um
someone's career
or whoever you're talking to but then
linking that to what they're watching at
this moment is that right yes and uh
like i had um
um mark guggenheim on who was like in
charge of like all of these cw
entertainment shows oh i thought that
was the facebook guy yeah yeah and all
of the um um all of those shows and then
to hear like what he's talking about
like when i have show runners on like
jay kogan who ran the simpsons and
fraser for a while to see he's watched
every single episode of like saturday
night live like and to hear like what
they're watching and why you know after
you talk to them like i had like buzzy
cohen on it was one of the uh jeopardy
champions and it's it's really
interesting because i was lizzy cohen
he's uh he was one of the jeopardy
champions yeah i was doing jeopardy okay
you got me i did
um
but it's uh it's always been fun because
everyone always surprises you too like i
had another comedian on and i was like
okay well i wonder what she's watching
and it was something like australian
procedural crime dramas like like
uh everyone thinks like well everyone
else is watching this or i'm watching
something that no one else is watching
it you get the whole spectrum of of
things that are watching some people are
watching youtube videos with a billion
views that i've literally never heard of
and uh so it's it's it's a fun show for
sure obviously love to have you guys
honest we would love to be on willian
captain are you in let's do a let's do a
very short episode just now and we'll
ask dom tom what are you watching i
don't know if that's the kind of stuff
you would ask that and chris maybe i'll
leave it to you
well yeah that's interesting that you
said youtube i've been telling billy for
a while now
i'm sure we all went through a whole
bunch of changes in our life during
covid
and one of the small changes for me
is that i kind of navigated towards
youtube instead of
watching what would be a movie or night
or or maybe two or three episodes of a
tv show at night i think maybe
based on the
stress levels of what was going on in
the world and all that kind of stuff
maybe i wanted something just a little
bit more bite size
so i was like well where can i watch
something that's 15 minutes long or 20
minutes long something like that
obviously youtube youtube has exploded
in terms of his content and the quality
of his content so i found myself
watching youtube shows you you know
long-form youtube things
nowadays my only criticism of that for
me personally is it has kind of fried
my brain a little bit last night i
watched a few good men because i was
just i was thinking i want to watch
something kind of procedural drama but
you know a classic something kind of
easy that i've seen before so watch a
few good men i put it on
and you know once i started i was like
oh this is like two and a half hours i
don't even know if i'm going to get
through two and a half hours thankfully
i did because it's it is a fantastic
film to break it up into youtube
sections yeah a little a little bit you
know um i'm trying to think of the last
i was i i was searching last night this
is how i got into a few good men i was
searching last night for
the most exciting films that have ever
been made
so
things like 12 angry men came up
the godfather lawrence of arabia and i
was like okay i've seen all those
they're a little long for me i'm looking
for something that maybe
i don't know i love gaspar noe's work
you know guest bonoy he did irreversible
and into the void pretty pretty tough
stuff to watch but there's no question
that you could say that they're exciting
but honestly i think the reason why i
got into this not that this is
necessarily my favorite film of all time
but just in terms of a movie going
experience it was just such a
a fun ride i wanted to watch something
similar to ready player one did you see
ready player one i did see ready player
one just yeah kind of
you know it's not going to change the
world but it's great fun and it's a
roller coaster um so from ready player
one it took me to a few good men which
is a strange little connection
it's a broken algorithm yeah
well what about what about you if you if
you were to potentially attempt to
answer that question is there anything
that jumps out in terms of oh well
here's his three
exciting movies no question that you
might want to check well i definitely um
really enjoyed everything and everywhere
all at once which just came out and uh
it was really good and it was also one
of those movies that you know you get
every once in a while where you watch
the movie and you're like well
clearly there were no studio notes here
this is a specific vision of the
filmmakers and the writers and the
directors and the actors and because how
would you know to move away you can't
you can't note a movie like that um yeah
so it was brilliant so inventive yeah
and you have a movie like that where you
can enjoy it all the more because you're
like okay well this is a very specific
vision and it worked the way it tied
together everything from
time travel to multiverse to um familial
drama to martial arts and it was like
well if you put all those things you
know in a box you'd be like well there's
no way that this would all come together
and they they pulled it off yeah it does
it works and putting jamie lee curtis in
as the
yeah it was costumes were amazing yeah
she was fantastic yeah really good and i
think uh dr strange i really enjoyed and
because i'm a big marvel fan and i
actually because i saw one division
before and the way it kind of um
the way it tied together with some of
the other marvel properties i really
enjoyed that and um the other movie that
i really really like that went under the
radar for a lot of people even though it
was an academy award uh nominated film
was drive my car
oh i've not seen it it's absolutely
fantastic but i will say this down it's
uh
it's great to watch
in smaller doses like if you break it up
and treat it more like a mini series is
it a long movie it's a super long movie
it's um i think three and a half hours
something like that and
it's uh part of the subplot is about a
play
so you have a lot of characters giving
monologues with subtitles and there's
really deep and there's a lot of layers
to them so it's because i knew like if i
watch this all the way through i'm gonna
drift after hour two so and i don't
wanna do that i wanna really give this
movie my full attention yeah and when i
broke it up and i was able to really
focus and concentrate on it i think i
enjoyed it all all the more drive my car
i'm writing it down um
fantastic i mean he was talking about
long films there some of my favorite
ever
film watching experiences
is knowing it's going to be long knowing
that
you're going to watch the godfather or
you're going to watch lawrence of arabia
or you're going to watch
you know
something that is pushing into the
three-hour mark and thinking okay this
is gonna get broken up there's gonna be
a moment where i'm gonna rush to the
bathroom put the kettle on grab a
biscuit maybe make a sandwich you know i
i like that kind of process you're like
okay half my day is being decadent and
watching a movie and you know even if
you saw it in a movie theater there was
an intermission anyway when those movies
came out right so you would get a break
regardless you're just you know it's
it's quicker and easier to go to the
bathroom and get a snack now do you
still go to the movie theater
i do just not as much um
because there's so many other choices in
the way things are being distributed and
shown through streaming uh but
everywhere and everything all at once i
just saw in the theater and i saw doctor
strange in the theater so those were the
two but i mean with the comedy film
nerds i was literally going every single
week i was and i would always go during
i would call it dad time i would go
fridays at 11 a.m where it was like me
and two other senior citizens in the
competitor no matter what movie it was
so but it was uh it was always a fun
time there is something weird
like even when you're saying and i
understand what you were saying about
cutting that movie up
um because
like how dense a kind of monologue would
be if it's
subtitled and all that but i wonder if
there is still something that we're
missing
as we don't go to the movie theaters as
much as we did because i noticed with my
son
who's very very into um
films and and filmmaking but older
movies
where you know the edit is a little
slower or
the storytelling's maybe a little slower
in the house he he can't focus on that
but if we got a uh an old classic uh
movie theater we can sit and watch those
movies and he'll enjoy them
so there must be something about sitting
in a community and the lights going out
and putting the focus on one thing that
does make you go okay
it's easier to sit here for two hours or
three hours than it is to sit on the
sofa where your phone's close by and the
kitchen's close by and you know i was
just gonna say i think this thing is the
real criminal because
i
i in the in the small moments in my life
where i do not like myself it's always
when i reach for my phone when i'm
having a great experience and i'm always
like what are you doing like oh i've got
a lot of other
other reasons yeah you've got a list
[Laughter]
but it's so bizarre that it's like fried
my brain i'll be like
watching the film and i'm like this is
fantastic let me tell my friends this is
fantastic this is a fantastic film
i can't take my eyes off the screen this
film is absolutely brilliant and then
you look back you're like wait wait what
what just happened i missed i missed it
yeah it's so annoying billy i was going
to ask you because i'm interested to see
if maybe i can mine another film out of
chris is there any particular kind of
you know
genre or or part of the movie world
where you're like i really like these
films
could you recommend this because i've
had exciting films so i've got drive my
car in the exciting film section but
i thought
i thought you're you're um i thought
your a
description of exciting or what you're
thinking of exciting is different to me
because like 12 angry men
i wouldn't put in a list of exciting
movies that would be in raiders of the
lost art and the matrix for me well
i i google searched you know the the
most exciting films of all time and a
lot of the lists that came up were ones
same as you where i was like that's not
exciting the godfather is you know you
know a thrilling movie and exciting at
times but i wouldn't necessarily say
that it's exciting as everything
everywhere all it was it's weird that
the internet list bots wouldn't get that
right yeah yeah i think more than
anything else what the what the list
bots were pulling up was the greatest
films of all time so i'd put the the
most exciting films of all time and they
were like oh they he means he means
films
yeah and you know the bots they're
they're very disrespectful they're
probably thinking well he won't know the
difference right right well i was just
gonna have you seen decalogue it's i
think he's called kozminski but that
might that might be totally wrong
this was a series of
ten films based around the ten
commandments so obviously with each
commandment they have a different film
and it was
consistent i think it's a polish
filmmaker consistently talked about by
stanley kubrick while he was alive as
his favorite series of films ever
i have not seen that it's tough to watch
you know european cinema you know
obviously subtitles which is fine i love
subtitles films but you know polish
there's not a huge amount of chuckles
and laughs in there it is an
extraordinary piece of work but you just
think about someone like kubrick who
obviously knew exactly what he was
talking about and he was like that is
the greatest series of films ever so
there you go chris there's one from me
nice all right and your podcast chris
was there any moments like that when a
guest
came up with a film and you're like oh
i've never seen that and then you went
back and watched it and thought how did
i miss that one
um that happened a lot yeah it happened
with comedy filmmakers and also is
happening
with what are you watching and it's it's
because it's tv shows too like one of
the things that i completely went under
my radar that
um a couple guests kept mentioning were
two shows uh dairy girls that's on
netflix right there which is absolutely
fantastic that i'd never heard of
and righteous gemstones on uh hbo max
and uh those were two shows i'm like
i've never heard of these and they're
like and then when i got them like you
know you almost get angry at yourself
how have i missed this
because they were so good and i had my
daughter watch dairy girls with me too
she's 17 and she's loving it too
there's just so much content out there
we can't give ourselves that much of a
hard time yeah um well billy should we
eat the world
billy and dom eat the world
so every week chris we we ask uh uh
illustrious guests to recommend a food
item that maybe maybe something that
you've grown up with or something that
you're very fond of or has a has a
special uh place in your in your heart
and in your stomach so you've
recommended something to us well to to
me because billy's not here
that we're gonna eat but do you want to
give us a little backstory blurb on it
absolutely uh as a kid this is a little
bit uh nostalgic this food choice um
growing up
we would always have like a jack and
jill ice cream truck that would drive
through our neighborhood and the things
that you would get there would either be
water rice or one of those cones that
you would take the top off would have
like chocolate on it and then you get
the cone and then you get the vanilla
ice cream so it was kind of like a
sunday all at once and uh
uh when trader joe's came out with these
hold the cone oh thank you
um i this kind of like hit the sweet
spot for me for the nostalgia of like i
remember this is kind of like what i
grew up with as a kid but they're also
smaller and i get less calories now so
as an adult i had to uh
um temper it with that as well
so billy you eat a cashew and we're
gonna eat a chocolate chip and chocolate
uh ice cream cone which i'm very excited
about where are you all right you're
starting with this is this just the
chocolate this is
i think this is the chocolate chip on it
oh smiley yeah enjoy your cashew but are
they salted billy they roasted yeah the
roasted the salted dum
and that looks good actually
now
billy and i did a podcast recently where
we asked a live audience do you like it
when we chew on the mic or do you not
like it when we chew on the mic and i
think
75
didn't like us chewing on the mic which
is a shame because i think i pushed the
tune on the mic thing more than anything
else
you know it's um i think it might be
universal podcast audience thing
um
we did an academy award show once for uh
comedy film nerds where it was live and
you know because the academy awards is
rather long so we had dinner in the
middle of it
forgot to turn the mics off
and
there was about 20 minutes uh 15 to 20
minutes sporadically of um the guests
listening to us also eat pizza and talk
about movies so
i can understand so can sometimes be a
little bit more obnoxious yeah it seemed
it seemed a
very high number of people
definitely didn't like to hear us uh our
mastication on on
yeah yeah yeah you should masticate in
private is what they're saying but you
wonder too could you win them over like
if you did it a different way would they
would they come around
well
billy has moved into that time in his
life i wonder if you're here chris where
he uh will apply uh food items to
different parts of his face and just
leave it there while he's eating my
dad's there my uncles are there
something happens when you get over the
age of 50. i'm five years away billy was
never like this i've known him for 20
years fastidious eater cleaned his face
and now we go out and he's got stuff on
his cheeks he's got stuff in his
sideburns stuff on his chin i don't know
how you do it
after 50 yeah our faces become magnetic
and it just
just grabs the food i think you've got
more gaps in your teeth as well
i think you have slight gaps in your
teeth that you never used to have that
where you could escape a part of a nut
or a crumb from say a pita bread and
find it on your chin
oh wait so you're saying that the gaps
in your teeth actually lead towards
holes in your face and that's where the
food ends up yeah no they'll come out
the whole
the gap in your tooth that you never
used to have it will get its way through
what what is called the hamster cheek
which is a lower part
and then it'll whip out onto here okay
well good i'll go with that theory
how how's that ice cream there's amazing
if you don't mind me really i know
they're really good
me and dom were just talking before you
come on there the uh so these are from
trader joe's right
and now i want a love i want to love
trader joe's because i've got so many
friends
who are like i'll be speaking to them
and i'll say what you doing today oh
after this i'm going to trade the jewels
i need to pick up the granola and these
ten dollars that i love and this
chocolate nut thing and
and it seems like trader joe's is a
place where people go
like not to get the day-to-day things
you know i'm going for my bread i'm
going for eggs kind of thing but they
have specific things like those
that they're like oh my god there's a
there's a trader joe's i'm gonna get
this and that and i want a list
of like seven or eight things
that
i go to and trader joe's and i can't
live without because i have nothing that
i go to to trade the jewels for and i
want those things the only thing i ever
get is that two buck chuck where you get
a bottle of wine for two dollars
seems like a good deal oh yeah yeah
trader joe's has figured out like that
weird niche of like we're only going to
stock food that you don't need but that
you really want yeah yeah that's yes
very interesting vibe but how do you
find those things that you really you
know my friend will say oh they have a
you know
pecan and honey granola that we can't
live without and you're like well when
did you pick that up when how did you
know
it uh trader joe's because they keep
their prices lower
you get to do a lot of trial and error
with their food so that's uh that's
really it really is more of uh um well
that looks good i'll try it if i like it
i'll buy it again yeah
and also
from a cultural point of view if we're
talking trader joe's uh i'm sure they
won't mind me saying this they're car
parks are right cheaters
they specifically set up haters car
parks less
less space than the actual people that
might be in trader joe's so i think what
they're trying to promote is get in get
out
leave
buy stuff and then f off hundred percent
no one's ever said boy the trader joe's
parking lots are great yeah so weird
though yeah
um well we're going to give these some
scores but i did want to ask you a
question chris um
what is there a
we were talking about this just before
we we started the show but i'd love to
bend your ear on it is there a genre of
movie
for you that is probably more your blind
spot than anything else uh yeah it's
probably sports movies well yeah because
i you know i'm not a a huge uh sports
fan so when a sports movie comes out
i'm like okay well i may not you know
quite relate to it the way like a
football fan or a basketball fan may
really enjoy like i could still enjoy
hoosiers but if you're watching it as a
fan
you're gonna enjoy it that much more so
i think that would probably be it all
right cool sports movies well i'm i'm
i'm a massive sports fan chris can i
leave you
on that thought with my favorite movie
of all time which i don't know if you've
ever seen it
dom will tell you what this is what is
it joe billy's favorite movie of all
time is gregory's girl
oh okay a classic have you seen it
i haven't no but now
now see i've it's i've already i'm
getting something on my list i'm going
to watch now wow
pitch it to him bills scotty's film made
by bill forsythe who made local hero
it was his i think he's
before local hero and it's about a high
school in scotland
uh and their their football team their
soccer team
and a girl
uh joins the soccer team and she's
brilliant she's a forward and scores all
the goals and the guy who was the
forward is then put in the goal and he
falls in love with her and it is
brilliant it's a wonderful coming-of-age
love story you will love it chris i'm
glad i could leave you with that watch
that tonight yes
absolutely that's a great from chris
like billy said charming and beautiful
and makes you laugh when you don't
expect it and maybe get a little tear in
your eye oh it's it is a classic it's an
absolute classic cool um well we should
give this some scores billy do you want
to score your cashew nuts for us are you
not interested i'll tell you what tom
when i when i have a cashew i normally
like to go uh organic and i'm not really
sure why
just because i feel like well it's a nut
it came straight from the ground
and then
so i feel as if it's if it was organic
it's coming right from the ground
roasted saltine straight into my mouth
there's no messing around these ones
aren't
they're from a company called beaver
they were tasty i'll give them eight out
of ten i like it i like the way they
look give them eight out of ten are they
useful very much so ten out of ten
oh lovely well that's high scores well
we should we should score these so we so
we score them on these things on three
categories chris
we do flavor or taste
aesthetics the way that it looks and
then billy's uh category usefulness
useful just go with us on that one he
won't he won't drink got it
i'm gonna try the chocolate one again
because it was absolutely decadent but
chris do you want to start with the
scores out of ten and you can do decimal
points if you feel yeah
well you know taste for me and with the
nostalgia factor it's definitely a a 10
out of 10 for me
um what was the second what was the
second category aesthetics the look
aesthetics you know what
they look okay but they are tiny and
they they're sometimes the top can get a
little lopsided so i would go probably
with a 7.5 on aesthetics
um usefulness
outside of it being an ice cream is
there anything yeah you can do with it
yeah
would you put it in your would you put
it into a blender blend it up create
some sort of cream that you then put on
a pie
or would you
that's i foreign was thinking well maybe
not yes that makes sense
because you could blend them together
you could also
yeah i mean if you found a tiny uh
relatively tame guinea pig you could put
it on his head on his head like it like
a kind of dance hat
and it could also
make maybe make it look like a dog or a
cat is eating a large ice cream cone
this is kind of like an instagram
picture lovely yep
the other thing is uh because it is
nostalgic it kind of makes me remember
those older uh ice creams that i had
when i was younger so i'm going to go
with a an 8.5 on usefulness lovely stuff
well uh-huh i'll give it some scores
chris i don't know if i don't want you
to slap me directly in the face but i'm
not really a big fan of ice cream oh i
don't care i think it's okay but if
someone said to me you can never eat an
ice cream again i wouldn't lose a
massive amount of uh sleep over it but i
enjoyed that ice cream
i like the chocolate uh chocolaty kind
of vibe so in terms of taste
i'm gonna give it an 8.8 nice i liked it
right yeah i know bills it's shocking um
uh aesthetics i agree with you i'm not
crazy on the slight lopsidedness of the
top although the uh chocolatey color of
the of the chocolate chip one is great
it's a seven
and then usefulness i'm fixated now on
the idea of
squishing it down on a guinea pig's head
because the ice cream itself would
probably fracture and cause a seal thus
keeping it on the guinea pig's head for
i would say a good 45 minutes to an hour
so
i'll give it
i'll give it a nine for use for wow yeah
there's a lot going on there i like the
cake i did useful it's a hit it's a
peter's head here's the reason why you
should be going to trader joe's bills
getting the mini ice cream well there's
one i tell you what if you're a trader
jewels guy chris give me another three
things as you get when i'm at trader
joe's uh okay this one is
lemon spin drift is really good it's a
uh it's it's a
sparkling water but it has actual lemon
juice in it so it tastes better than
like an artificial like tasting uh uh
yeah sparkling water
a lot of good trail mix over at trader
joe's you know you could kind of get you
know your your
is just cashews is that uh
you could get that with maybe m ms or
something else you could get yeah yeah
you could uh you could get that but you
could get it jazzed up so you could have
it with other nuts and other candies as
well
uh
and the one staple that we always get
and i don't know why they're so good i
couldn't explain it to you you'd have to
have a scientist on um the
gluten-free toaster waffles are amazing
well i enjoy a waffle as much as the
next man
so if it's gluten-free
people don't like gluten these days so
i'll join that bandwagon i don't care if
it can go straight in the toaster yeah
yeah i'll give that a try chris and i'll
come back to you on that let me know
please get me to a trader joe's um well
chris it's been fantastic having you on
we would love to do your podcast where
do you where do you record the podcast
that you do i record in la but it's uh
it's virtual so you can do you guys uh
um you know
well we can no matter where you guys are
we can do uh yeah we can do uh um
we can
what do you call it be me in yeah you
could do that yeah yeah yeah you could
uh billy's currently in an undisclosed
location but you'll be back in los
angeles sometimes soon won't you bills
canada it's not undisclosed no well i
wanted you to disclose it
but yeah and i'd love to have you guys
on and we'll do it remotely and you know
tell me more about what you guys are
watching and now if we come on do we
need to do any homework do we need to
think these are the five things that we
need to talk about is there any like
because obviously we had you do homework
sure to bring food all you have to do
and this is something that everyone's
you just have to watch something before
the show and it could be a tv movie um
anything that's it
was it was the new ben stiller thing
i've been watching that
severance
oh very good you watched that yet chris
i haven't but that's another show that
everyone's saying you have to watch it
but the problem is that you have to
watch it shows that people tell you that
list has gotten longer absolutely so
it's hard to get to everything but
that's definitely on my list to get to
yeah billy and i flew together on a
plane recently i think we were coming
back from calgary and billy uh was
watching severance and just before the
plane took off he showed me his computer
he went look i'm gonna watch severance
and i went oh great anyway yeah and he
put his headphones on and then he took
his computer screen and he went
so there was no chance that i could
watch it on mew and i thought oh well
there you go
i don't like to share i don't like to
share food movies good times nah
it's all for me
was he afraid you'd ask for like one of
the ear buds you could share that yeah
yeah what's going on what's going on
yeah how come he shouted at that person
well chris thanks a lot for coming uh
thanks for bringing the ice creams
uh thanks for being a fantastic guest oh
my pleasure thanks for having me guys
i've learned a lot all the best with
your new podcast uh what's it called
again for the people out there it's uh
what are you watching with chris mancini
and uh the quiet journeys of professor
atwood those are the two and wonderful
chris brought us two wonderful graphic
novels which we should just very quickly
shout out at the end of the show long
ago and far away chris's recent graphic
novel uh
it looks super exciting and something
that i think that you would like
especially builds because you're into uh
martial arts rise of the kung fu
dragon master
and guys we will see you next week
toodles on the friendship onion
[Music]
harmonize with me and hold me right up
all through the night you're shining
bright i'm your boy's the baby you're my
pearl